[موسيقى]
توقعتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض التي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز وعناوين
اليوم
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم لكيف ودعوات اوروبيه للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
عمان تسجل هزه ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات
على مقياس ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
وفي الرابعه كذلك
مشروع لتحويل فائض الاطعمه والمشروبات الى
سوق غير ربحيه شرقي السعوديه
حياكم الله اختوتي ما قبل قليل المؤتمر
ميونخ للامن في المانيا وفي كلمه له في
المؤتمر شدد مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي على ضروره تطوير دور
التكتل الدفاعي والسبراني وخلال الكلمه
اكد بوريل ضروره زياده وتسريع المساعدات
العسكريه الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا اضاف
المسؤول الاوروبي انه على دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان ترسل ما لديها من الذخيره ثم
تستبدلها ولا تنتظر كي تشتري ذخائر جديده
وترسلها وقال بوريل انه على المدى المتوسط
يجب زياده قدره الانتاج الدفاعي الاوروبي
شريطه ان تكون هنا كذا خائير كافيه لكافه
الدول على حد تعبيره
روسيا تحاول تحويل المعركه مع اوكرانيا
الى حرب اشمل مع الغرب وعلى الدول
الاوروبيه تقاسم الاعباء الدفاعيه والدفاع
عن قيام ومبادئ الامم المتحده كما يجب
تطوير دور التكتل الدفاعي والسيبراني خلال
الفتره المقبله الى جانب التركيز على
تقديم المزيد من الذخائر لاوكرانيا
ومن ميونخ تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام راغده مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معنا في نشره الرابع من الرياض ما الذي
يمكن اجماله في اليوم الاخير لمؤتمر ميونخ
للامن
راغده طيب يبدو اننا
نواجه مشكله في الصوت والصوره من من
المصدر سنعود مره اخرى الى الزميله راغده
بهنام حاله جاهزه هذا المباشر وفي هذه
النشره ايضا قال المتحدث باسم الكريملين
ان روسيا لا ترى اي انفتاح على مبادرات
السلام من جانب الغرب بخصوص اوكرانيا
واضاف بيسكوف ان تصريحات وكيله وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون السياسيه
فيكتوريا نولاند حول اعتبار القرم هدفا
مشروعا لكيف واشنطن تؤكد عمق الخلاف بين
امريكا وروسيا مشددا على ان هذه التصريحات
تعكس دور واشنطن الرئيسي في اثاره
التوترات العالميه
نعود مره اخرى الى زميل راغده بهنام والتي
تلتحق بنا من ميونخ راغده مرحبا بك معي في
نشاط الرابع من الرياض اليوم اختتم
المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ للامن الذي يمكن
اجماله في اليوم الاخير
راغده
طيب يبدو ان الزميل راغدا نواجه مشاكل
تقنيه معها من المصدر سنحاول العوده اليها
ان امكن في هذه النشره وفي ذات المؤتمر
شدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
ابن فرحان على ان العوده للاتفاق النوويه
الايراني يجب ان تكون بنظره شموليه
وبمشاركه خليجيه جاء ذلك اثناء جلسه
حواريه شارك فيها في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه اكد ان موقف
السعوديه واضح من العلاقات مع ايران مشيرا
الى وجود حوار معها وحول الوضع في الشرق
الاوسط بين الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان
الرياضه تعمل مع واشنطن على قضايا تخص امن
واستقرار المنطقه مع مراعاه المصالح
القوميه
حول الوضع في سوريا قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان اجماعا
عربيا بدات تشكل والتزايد حول انعدام جدوى
عزل سوريا وان الحوار مع دمشق مطلوب في
وقت ما حتى تتسنى على الاقل معالجه
المسائل الانسانيه الاكثر اهميه بما في
ذلك عوده اللاجئين خاصه بعد وقوع زلزال
المدمر في سوريا وتركيا الامير فيصل اوضح
ايضا ان حاجه الدول العربيه لحل جديد في
سوريا يتزايد في ظل غياب السبل لتحقيق
الاهداف القصوى من اجل حل سياسي حول سؤاله
عن تقارير تتحدث عن انه قد يزور دمشق بعد
ان زارها نظيره الاماراتي والاردني بعد
الزلزال قال الامير فيصل بن فرحان انه لن
يعلق على الشائعات
مره اخرى نعود الى الزميله راغده بهنام من
ميونخ راغده مرحبا بك هل تسمعينني اولا
اليوم اختتم هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن
تصريحات اللقاءات ايضا ربما مواضيع كانت
بارسه بارزه على يعني جدول هذه
الجدول هذا المؤتمر والقمم التي عقدت في
ما الذي يمكن اجماله في اليوم الاخير
راغده
[موسيقى]
بالفعل الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت طاغيه على
اعمال هذا المؤتمر منذ اليوم الاول وحتى
اليوم الاخير في الواقع ربما كان بارز
ايضا بانه هناك خلافات ربما تتعمق اكثر
بين الدول الغربيه والصين بسبب علاقه
الصين مع روسيا كان هناك يوم امس لقاء
مساء بين وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والمبعوث
الصيني المسؤول الصيني الموجود هنا ولكن
يعني اليوم كان ليكن يقول في مقابله لقناه
امريكيه بانه هو ابلغ المسؤول الصيني بانه
اذا ما خطط الصين خطوه اضافيه وزودت روسيا
بمعدات عسكريه او بمساعدات عسكريه فهذا
سيؤثر بشكل كبير على العلاقه الثنائيه بين
الولايات المتحده وبين الصين ويعني ايضا
قال بانه ابلغه او يعني اعتراض الولايات
المتحده على مساله
البالون الصيني الذي يعني شكل كان في
عناوين الاخبار الاسبوع الماضي ولكن من
جهه اخرى ايضا كنا سمعنا من الم المسؤول
الصيني هنا انتقادات شديده اللهجه
للولايات المتحده وصف رد فعلها على مساله
البالون بانه رد فعل هستيري لذلك بالفعل
هناك مخاوف الان من امكانيه زياده هذا
الدور زياده هذه العلاقه او يعني ان تكون
هناك علاقه عسكريه بين الصين وروسيا من
جهه ايضا مخاوف اخرى ظهرت هنا
واضحه بانه تشكل مصدر قلق رئيسي بالنسبه
للدول الغربيه هي العلاقه العسكريه كذلك
بين روسيا وايران يوم امس يعني كان يقول
لي دبلوماسي غربي رفيع بانه الان مساله
التعاطي مع ايران يعني على اجنده على
راسها هي وقطع علاقتها العسكريه بروسيا
وبانه يعني هذا الامر الان بات مستر قراب
كبير بالنسبه للدول الغربيه لذلك ربما
يمكن القول بانه التركيز الان على مواجهه
هذين التحديين الجديدين بالطبع اضافه الى
مناقشه مساله امن اوروبا الذي يعني كان
اليوم موضوع نقاش سمعنا من جزر فبراير
المفوض الشؤون الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعو الدول الاوروبيه لعدم التردد وللسرعه
في ارسال الذخائر والمساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا المستقبل الاوروبي ايضا كذلك مع
روسيا ربما يعني ملامحه في هذه القمه بدات
تتضح بشكل كبير يعني لا عوده اولا خط رجعه
للعلاقات معها وكذلك التاكيد على ضروره
زياده طبعا
الدفاعات في هذه الدول الاوروبيه زياده
الانفاق الدفاعي
وكذلك ايضا الموضوع الصيني الامريكي ما
الذي يعني من نقاشات
اهم شيء ربما على هذه المواضيع والتي
رصدتيها انت ايضا كذلك
يعني كان هناك ربما موضوع خارج هذا
الموضوع موضوع الحرب في اوكرانيا يتعلق
بايران والاحتجاجات القائمه هناك كان هناك
جلسه شارك فيها ناشطين ناشطون ايرانيون
ويعني مسؤولون في البرلمانات الاوروبيه
ربما هذه كانت الجلسه الوحيده التي لم تكن
لها علاقه مباشره يعني او من الجلسات
القليله التي لم تكن لها علاقه مباشره
بالحرب في اوكرانيا والتي تحدثت عن ضروره
ان يزيد المجتمع الغربي دعمه للمحتاجين
وان يعزل النظام الايراني اكثر سمعنا ايضا
من رئيس او رئيس المجلس الرئاسي اليمني
ايضا يتحدث عن يعني رفض الحوثيين الانصياع
او يعني اتخاذ ايه خطوات لانهاء هذه الحرب
وقال بانه اتفاقيات ستوكه التي التزمت بها
الحكومه اليمنيه لم تجد يعني من قبل
الحوثيين اي تحرك يشير الى انهم يعني
يريدون ان يقتل انهاء هذه الحرب القائمه
هناك لذلك اليوم ايضا صباحا كان هناك جلسه
تتعلق بمساله السلام في الشرق الاوسط شارك
فيها وزير الخارجيه الاردني
وسمعنا منه تحذير بانه الوضع في يعني
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ربما يتجه نحو انتفاضه
جديده ويعني كانت هناك انتقادات لسياسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه بتوسيع
المستوطنات
يعني كل ما الى ذلك لذلك بالفعل بعض
المواضيع الجانبيه التي لم تكن لها علاقه
مباشره بالحرف اوكرانيا ولكن لم تاخذ حيز
كبير حتى العلاقه الامريكيه الصينيه التي
توترت بعد حادثه المنطاد على كل حال شكرا
جزيلا لك من ميونخ انضمت الينا مراسله
العربيه راغبه
نفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه سقوط قتلا في
الضربه الاسرائيليه على دمشق وريفها
بسوريا واشارت الى ان الهجوم الاسرائيلي
نفذ على مرحلتين الاولى في دمشق والثاني
في السويداء المزيد في هذا التقرير
تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات وعناصر
تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني خلال العام
الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي طار كفر سوسه
الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه ضحيته 15 شخصا
وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان تلك
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت مواقع
تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب الله
اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
الثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي الثاني من
يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر جراء الضربات
الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا
رابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشرات الالاف السوريين من
تركيا
حياكم الله من جديد مع مرور 14 يوما على
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
تجاوز عدد الضحايا اربعين الف قتيل والاف
المفقودين وسائل الاعلام التركيه كشفت عن
تسجيل هزه ارضيه جديده بقوه
وسبعه من عشره في ملاطيا فيما يستمر نزوح
المتضررين من الولايات المنكوبه في تركيا
الى مناطق اخرى بحثا عن ماوى ومكان اكثر
امانا وتبدا السلطات التركيه كذلك بحصر
جميع الاضرار جراء الزلزال غدا الاثنين
فيما تجري حاليا عمليات التثبت من الجثث
المجهوله عبر فحص الحمض النووي وحول هذا
الامر ايضا دعا وزير الداخليه التركي
سليمان سويلو المواطنين للتوجه الى مراكز
مخصصه في كل ولايه للحصول على عينه دم
لاجراء الفحص وتسهيل التعرف على اصحاب
الجثث مجهوله الهويه
ومعنا من غازي عنتاب زيدان زين كلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض يعني ربما اخر الهزات
الارضيه التي تم رصدها هذا اليوم هي في
منطقه ملاتيا
في تركيا الى اي مدى هذه الهزه كانت بشكل
قوي ما الذي رصدته حولها ايضا بدايه
نعم لا شك نايف ان الهزات الارتداديه ما
زالت تثير خوف السلطات التركيه لاسيما ان
هناك العديد وهو مئات والاف المباني
المتصدعه والايره للسقوط هذه الهزات ان
كان في ملاطها قبل قليل وكانت بقوه 4.7
على مقياس ريختر او يوم امس هزه ارتداديه
كانت هنا في غازي عنتاب تجاوزت خمس درجات
تجاوزت شدتها خمس درجات على مقياس ريختر
طبعا لا شك ان كل هذه الازات يشعر بها
سكان المنطقه هذه الازاد تثير الزعر لدى
سكان هذه المناطق وايضا السلطات التي تخشى
من سقوط ابنيه جديده لذلك السلطات حصلت او
يعني تقريبا قدرت حتى الان عمليات البحث
ما زالت مستمره نايف لكن حتى الان اعداد
المباني التي تهدمت بشكل كامل او بشكل
جزئي او او مباني تصدعت ولا يمكن السكن
تجاوز عدد هذه المباني
84,600 مبنى بالتالي هذه المباني سيتم
هدمها بشكل عاجل للبدء استعدادا للبدء في
عمليه اعاده الاعمار كما نشاهد هنا في هذا
المكان الذي وصلناه قبل قليل هنا في
اصلاحيه يتم تشييد 300
مبنى جديد هي عباره عن كرفانات هنا تسمى
كرفانات وهي اماكن ايواء مؤقته لنقل 300
عائله تعيش في الخيام الى هذه المنطقه
التي نشاهدها الان الاليات تعمل على مدار
الساعه لمحاوله في محاوله انجاز هذا
الموضوع او انجاز هذا السكن المؤقت في
اسرع وقت وكما ذكرت نايف هناك حالات نزوح
كبيره من هذه المناطق الى مناطق اكثر امنا
النزوح ساعود اليك فيها زيدان لكن اريد ان
اسال عن اليه تقييم المنازل واضرار
المنازل ايضا حتى كذلك في غ از عنتاب كيف
تجري هذه الامور اشرح لنا اكثر
نعم بشكل عام تم يعني تم تجنيد اكثر من
7000 مختص في كل الولايات المتضرره لفحص
كل المباني الموجوده في هذه الولايات يتم
البدء في فحص هذه المباني مراقبه الاساسات
الجدران الطوابق بشكل كامل وكل منزل على
حده ومن ثم يتم تقييم الاضرار بشكل عام في
حال كان المبنى
يمكن اصلاحه واجراء عمليات ترميم يتم
تقييمه انه من ضمن المباني التي يمكن
ترميمها وبالتالي هذه المباني سترمم في
وقت قريب جدا اما في حال كانت المباني غير
مناسبه للسكن وفيها خطوره على سكان هذه
المنازل يتم تقييمها بانها مباني او يتم
اعطاء اشاره اليها بانها مباني ستهدم
وبالتالي يحضر على سكانها العوده اليها
وهذا طبعا
كما ذكرت عمليه التقييم ما زالت مستمره في
كل الولايات اكثر من 7000 مختص هم من
يقومون بهذه العمليه ممتاز بالنسبه
للنازحين كنت تشير الى نقطه قبل قليل
زيدان يعني اريد ان تفصل لنا فيها اكثر
طبعا هي واضحه الصور معنا الان ربما بعض
الخيام الموجوده في
في خلف طبعا
الزميل او خلف الزميل زيدان زين كل زيدان
تفضل
في كل المناطق المتضرره نحن هنا في مدينه
اصلاحيه تقريبا في كل منطقه في اصلاحيه
هناك تجمع لعشرات الخيام طبعا سكان هذه
الخيام بعضهم فضل ان يذهب بشكل منفرد الى
اقاربه وذويه في ولايات اخرى لذلك حركات
النزوح ما تزال مستمره بعضهم ينتظر
المساكن المؤقته للسكن في هذه المساكن
المؤقته لك هذا المشروع الذي نشاهده
امامنا الان وبالتالي هناك سيتم ايواء
الكثير من متضرر من متضرري الزلزال في هذه
المشاكل لكن قبل قليل وفي جوله هنا في
مدينه اصلاحيه كنت التقي مع
لاجئين سوريين وهذه المدينه استضافت الاف
اللاجئين السوريين خلال السنوات الماضيه
وكثيرا كثير كثير منهم مع الاسف يعني لقي
حتفه بسبب الزلز الكثير منهم ما زال يقيم
في خيم بعضهم اخبرني ان موظفين من اداره
الهجره كانوا يجولون عليهم اثناء تواجدنا
في هذا المكان طلبوا منهم مغادره اصلاحيه
الى مخيم نيزيب في ولايه غازي عنتاب هم
يخشون حقيقه من ذهابهم الى هناك وعدم
توفير اماكن مناسبه لهم
اماكن ايواء لهم لذلك هم يتخوفون من هذه
الخطوه حاولنا ان نسال موظفي
اداره الهجره عن هذا الموضوع لكنهم لم
يؤكدوا او ينفوا هذه المعلومات وتبقى هذه
المعلومات بوحده اللاجئين الذين اخبرون
بهم لكن سالنا العديد منهم والجميع اكد
هذه المعلومه لكنه موظفي اداره الهجره
رفضوا التعليق على هذا الموضوع طبعا غازي
عنتاب هي من المدن التي انتهت فيها طبعا
يعني عمليات ربما البحث او الانقاذ او
التقصي عن ناجين تحت يعني انقاض المنازل
المهدمه زيدان
نعم نعم بالضبط قبل ايام تم الاعلام بشكل
رسمي عن انتهاء اعمال البحث والانقاذ
والان هناك تجري في بعض المواقع ازاله
الانقاض استعدادا للبدء بعمليه اعاده
الاعمار هذه العمليه التي من المنتظر ان
تبدا في مطلع مارس القادم طبعا باشراف
مؤسسه توكي وهي مؤسسه اسكان حكوميه هي
التي ستشرف على شروط تنفيذ الابنيه
ومواصفات الابنيه التي ستكون مضاده
للزلازل وتم اختيار الاراضي التي والمناطق
التي ستقام فيها المشاريع الجديده طبعا من
المنتظر ان تبدا الحكومه في مطلع مارس
ببناء ثلاثين الف وحده سكنيه بحسب
مسؤولين حكوميين ان مناقصات ستبدا خلال
ايام قليله بشكل متزامن في عديد الولايات
على ان يتم البدء بمشاريع اضافيه
لاستكمال عمليات اعاده الاعمار خلال
الفتره لكن كما ذكرنا كل العمليات ستكون
باشراف الوزارات المعنيه وتحديدا مؤسسه
توكي هذه المؤسسه المسؤوله عن عشرات
المشاريع ومئات المشاريع في كل الولايات
التركيه وحتى الان يعني بحسب تصريحات
وتاكيداتوكي ان كل المباني والمشاريع
السكنيه التي قاموا بانشائها في الولايات
العشره لم تتضرر ابدا بالزلزال لان
مواصفاتها كانت مطابقه للمعايير الموضوعه
لمكافحه الزلازل شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل من غازي عنتاب زيدان
كلو مراسله العربيه
وسط تردي ظروف المنكوبين جراء زلزال في
سوريا دعت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى زياده
المساعدات الانسانيه الى شمال غرب سوريا
بشكل عاجل اشاره المنظمه الى انه في
الايام العشره التي اعقبت الزلزال كان عدد
الشاحنات التي عبرت الى شمال غرب سوريا
اقل من معدلها الاسبوعي في العام 2022
ياتي ذلك تزامنا مع دخول 14 شاحنه للمنظمه
محمله بالف ومئتين وتس خيمه ومستلزمات
لمواجهه البرد لنازحين وعائلات شردها
الزلزال عبر معبر الحمام في منطقه عفرين
كانت المنظمه استنفدت مخزونها في ادلب بعد
وقوع الزلزال عبر تقديمي حوالي 12 طنا
و4,000 متر مكعب من المعدات الجراحيه
والادويه لمستشفيات ادلب
من جانبها قالت نائبه المبعوث الوهم الخاص
لسوريا نجاه رشدي ان الامم المتحده ملتزمه
تماما ببذل المزيد لمساعده جميع السوريين
مضيفه ان في سوريا تاثر ما لا يقل عن
ثمانيه ملايين شخص بالزلزال المدمر كما من
المتوقع ان يحتاج غالبيتهم الى شكل من
اشكال المساعدات الانسانيه
اشار وزير الدفاع التركي الى عوده اكثر من
عشره الاف سوريين في تركيا الى سوريا طوعا
دون الاشاره الى مزيد من التفاصيل وذلك
منذ ان ضرب زلزال عنيف اجزاء واسعه من
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا ووفقا لبيانات
الامم المتحده تعد تركيا اكبر الدول
المضيفه للاجئين السوريين في العالم وفقا
لبيانات الامم المتحده
وعلى صعيد الجهود الاغاثيه يقدم مستشفى
صحه الافتراضي التابع لوزاره الصحه
السعوديه خدماته للمتضررين من الزلزال عبر
تقديم الاستشارات الطبيه والفحوص عن بعد
المدير التنفيذي الطبي لمستشفى صحه
الافتراضيه الدكتور عبد العزيز الحمود
يعطينا لمحه عن اليه عمل المستشفى
العمل هذا
يتطلب تضافر جهود ممكن فريق الهلال الاحمر
موجود على الارض
بتواصل مباشر مع المتضررين من هالكوارث
وهالزلازل وبدعم من
وتنسيق بمركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه
باستخدام التقنيه لدينا الاجهزه لدينا
وسائل تجهيز العياده التقنيه او
الافتراضيه عن بعد هناك وطبيب من الموجود
في المستشفى الافتراضي يستطيع التواصل مع
المريض بشكل مباشر مثل المستشفى الافتراضي
او الاطباء الموجودين جزء منهم من فريق
المستشفى والجزء الاخر تم استقطاطهم عن
طريق برامج اخرى متوفره في السعوديه تق وم
بفحص شامل للحاله تقوم باستخدام بعض
التقنيات للفحص الدقيق حتى نبض القلب او
ما الى ذلك يستطيع طبيب لا هنا عن طريق
التواصل يسمع ويفحص القلب يفحص النبضات
يفحص التنفس يوفر الدواء ينصح بالخطوه
القادمه الحمد لله كل هذه تكون متوفره من
هنا الحمد لله
تصل قصير نتبع بعده الرابع
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم الكييف ودعوات اوروبيه
للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
عمان تسجل هزه ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات
على مقياس ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
مشروع لتحويل فائض الاطعمه والمشروبات الى
سوق غير ربحيه شرقي السعوديه
حياكم الله في اخبار الزلازل اعلنت سلطنه
عمان عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه بقوه 4.1 درجات
على مقياس ريختر وفقا لمركز رصد الزلزال
او الزلازل في جامعه السلطان قابوس فان
الهزه سجلت في مدينه الدقم على الساحل
الجنوبيه الشرقي للسلطنه وبين المركز ان
الشعور بالهزه كان خفيفا في الدقم وغير
محسوس في المدن الاخرى بما فيها العاصمه
مسقط واشار المرصد الى ان الشده الزلزاليه
تختلف من موقع الى اخر ومن مبنى الى اخر
وفقا لارتفاعها وطبيعه التربه
من مسقط ينضم الينا الدكتور عيسى الحسين
مدير مركز رصد الزلازل بجامعه السلطان
قابوس دكتور عيسى مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض بدايه ما الذي رصدتموه
هذه الاجزال الارضيه في سلطنه عمان
مرحبا بك اخ نايف والساده المشاهدين طبعا
حدث هزه ارضيه صباح اليوم بالسبعه وخمسه
وخمسين دقيقه
بمقدار
اربع واحد من عشره بمقياس الزلازل كانت
على عمق 18 كيلو متر هذا العمق يعتبر عميق
الى حد ما حيث تبدل معظم الطاقه تمتصها
الارض ويصل منها جزء بسيط على على سطح
الارض على شكلها الذات
حدث في محافظه الوسطى وهي محافظه غيرة
وهذا الزلزال من النوع الخفيف عاده حتى لو
شعر بها المواطنين وزلزال غير مؤثر الا
على بهالشكل محدود جدا على المباني
الطينيه او المتهالك
والزلزال سجل لكن غير غير مؤثر وبالتالي
هذا يعني هذا المستوى من الهزات الارضيه
لا يوجد له هزات ربما ارتداديه او تبعات
خطيره دكتور
نعمل هزات الهزات معظم الهزات الارضيه
الكبيره او كل الهزات الارضيه الكبيره لها
توابع ذات الخفيفه مثل هذه نادر ما يكون
الها توابع اذا كان تكون خفيفه جدا جدا او
ضعيفه في مستوى لا يمكن الاحساس بها فقط
باجهزه رصد الزلازل الحساسه جدا
الزلازل الخفيفه التوابع انها اتوقع ان
يحدث لها
طيب دكتور يعني علميا هل يمكن
يعني الربط بينما حدث في تركيا وسوريا
اتحدث هنا عن الربط يعني
المنطقه ككل بانها ربما تعيش مرحله من
مرحله الهزات او الزلازل او او ما الى ذلك
لانها لم تسجل الهزات فقط مثلا في في
سوريا وتركيا سجلت في دول اخرى ايضا في
محيطها
نعم هو احنا نتكلم عن الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه العربيه
مترابطه طبعا واللي ما حدث في شمال
غرب الصفيحه العربيه في شمال شمال غرب
سوريا والجنوب شرق تركيا او جنوب تركيا هو
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من الصفيحه العربي
احنا بالجزائر الشرق من سكان
عاده البحوث العلميه تثير تشير الى بعض
الاحيان ان بعض الزلازل تحفز الزلازل اخرى
على صدور اخرى على الاغلب تكون الصدوع
قريبه منها يعني يسمونه
انكسر
الضغوط خفت عليه صدى اخر مجاور او بالقرب
منه
ينشط زلزاليا اما بهذا البعد مسافه تقريبا
اكثر من 3000 كيلو تقريبا من
سبع شرق الاناضول
والمحافظه بعيد جدا لاحتمال مثل هذا يعني
حتى لو كان محفز يعني تحفيز بسيط جدا يعني
القوه الناتجه على التحفيز بهذا المجال هي
اجزاء بسيطه عشريه من البار فتكون ضعيفه
جدا
رغم رغم وجود يعني تاكيد علمي انه الزلازل
تحرض بعضها على الانتاجيه بس بعد المكان
بعد الجغرافي نستبعد انه هذا التحريض من
زلزال تركي وبالتالي التحريض من الزلزال
تركي ربما يكون يا دكتور للدول المحاذيه
او القريبه مثلا من سوريا
من خليج العقبه البحر الميت الى الغاب
بالسوريه الى جنوب شرق تركيا لهذا نعتبر
يعتبر خط زلزال طويل جدا مشابه له في بين
البحر العربي والمحيط الهندي لمتد من
الصومال الى حدود باكستان هذول الصدعين هم
يستاهلوا انزلاق الصفيحه
الشرق والشمال الشرقي
اللي حدث عليه زلزال تركيا
يعني سبع شرق قال انا ظلم وامتداد جنوبا
الى خليج العقبه يعني ممكن يحفز زلازل في
لبنان في سوريا في فلسطين
وعاده تكون متتابعه وتكون زلازل صغيره
للمتابع اغلبها تكون صغيره ممكن تكون
محسوسه لكن غير مؤثره الا على الاباني
التي هي انهكت وصارت يعني اصبحت متهلكه او
ايلونس انت تقصد يا دكتور بانها غير
محسوسه لان اليوم اداره هيئه الكوارث
التركيه مثلا اعلنت بان هناك 640 هزه
ارتداديه سجلت بعد زلزال المدمر والعنيف
الذي ضرب في السادس من فبراير وبالتالي
لازم ازاله الارتداديه دكتور هل هل تكون
في محيط
الزلزال ام ابعد من من هذه المنطقه
الجغرافيه
كل الزلازل الكبيره تحدث الا عندها
التوابع والتوابع احيانا تكون كبيره الى
حد ما وتكون مؤثره والكثير منها يكون
زلازل صغيره لانه الزلزال الضخم هو فرغ
معظم الطرق وكسر اكبر نتوء على سطح الفالق
اما النتوءات الاخرى على سطح الفالق
فتتالا بانكسارها تباعا ممكن بعضها الاكبر
وبعضها الاصغر وحجم هو ينتج منها زلزال
متوسط الى زلازل خفيفه الاحساس بالزلزال
لا يعني ان الزلزال مؤثر يعني اذا مرت من
جنبنا شاحنه او قطار نشعر باهتزاز المبنى
فهذا اهتزاز
موكل زلزال تشعر به انه يعني يجب ان يكون
مؤثرا على المبنى يعني احنا نعيش في بيئه
والبيئه
مترابطهزاز احيانا يكون صحي لانه تنفس
الزلازلات
يعني تنتج الضغوط على الصدع بشكل جرعات
وتكون زلازل صغيره احسن ما تتجمع وتصير
زلزال اكبر دكتور أنتم من خلال رصدكم يعني
في جامعه السلطان قابوس في رصه الزلازل
وبالنسبه لعمان او ايضا حتى دول
الخليج هل يعني تتوقعون او مثلا ترصدون او
تتنبؤون ايضا بالزلازل قبل ان تقع
بخطورتها ايضا كذلك نريد ان نفهم هذه
النقطه لانها مثار جدا للدكتور دائما انه
هل يمكن التنبؤ بالزلزال ام استحاله
التنبؤ فيه ايضا وفي نطاق الجغرافي كذلك
يطرح دائما هو التنبؤ بالزلزال الى الان
العلم لم يتوصل الى الى طريقه علميه متسقه
وموثقه تتنبا بالزلزال هناك ظواهر قبل
الزلزال العلماء عاده وصلوا الى نوع من
التوقع يتوقعوا النطاقات الزلزال ويحددوا
اكبر قدر زلزالي على كل نطاق زلزالي اما
التنبؤ بالزمان هذا اللي الى الان استحاله
تحديد التنبؤ حتى يكون التنبؤ مفيد الي
والك وللمشاهدين والمهندسين لازم يتوفر في
عناصر الوقت وهو لازم كل هذا الوقت حتى
يكون مفيد
والمكان والقوه واحتماليه وقوع هذا الزفاف
اذا ما توفرت كل هذه العناصر واهمها الوقت
يبقى
نسمي توقع او فوركاس فقط اشكرك جزيل الشكر
والمسقط انضمي لان الدكتور عيسى الحسين
مدير مركز رصد الزلازل بجامعه السلطان
قابوش قابوس
اطلقت جمعيه اطعام في المنطقه الشرقيه اول
سوبر ماركت غير ربحي والسيمو في حفظ
الموارد الغذائيه من الهدر وتقديم حلول
التامين الغذائي المستدام للاسر المستفيده
والافراد واول سوبر ماركت سحابيه عبر
سلسله فروع لتطوير خدمات الدعم الغذائي
وتوفير منافذ التوزيع السحابيه لفروع
اطعام
بجمعيه بنك الطعام السعودي اطعام
ومن مقر جمعيه اطعام بالدمام ينضموا الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد
الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بكم معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض عبد الرحمن ماذا لديك
اليوم انت ربما موجود في بنك الطعام هذا
غير الربحي
نعم نايف نحن من وحده التعبئه المركزيه في
جمعيه اطعام هذه الجمعيه التي شكلت نموذجا
ناجحا لعمل الجمعيات الخيريه عبر تطور
العمل بها منذ تاسيسه حتى اليوم هذا
النجاحات اليوم تبلورت في اعلان عدد من
المبادرات وعدد من الشراكات ومذكرات
التفاهم عدد من القطاعات الحيويه في
السعوديه لعل ابرزها هو السوبر ماركت غير
الربحي السحابي الذي سيشكل نقله نوعيه في
جمعيات اطعام المحتاجين والمستفيدين بدايه
دعنا نستضيف الاستاذ
منصور
الشوشان فيصل الشوشان عذرا فيصل بدايه
الرئيس التنفيذ طبعا لجمعيه الطعام لماذا
هذا التوجه اليوم
فيما يتعلق بالسواكه السحابي وغير الربح
طبعا سنشاهد بعد قليل لقطات لهذا السوبر
ماركت الذي كان نموذج اليوم في
توسعت عملياتنا بشكل كبير تنوعت المنتجات
في تداخل كبير في الاغذيه دخولنا على
الطعام الجاف جهود الدوله اليوم في مساله
الامن الغذائي رؤيه المملكه عشرين ثلاثين
احد محاولها الرئيسيه هو دعم الامن
الغذائي في حراك كبير في هذا الملف لابد
ان اكون جزء نحن من هذا الحراك نعمل على
الابتكار في صناعه النماذج المبتكره في
القطاع غير ربحي تخصصها في الغذاء قررنا
التوجه بهذه الطريقه وهو توجه خاص باطعام
ولد من الجمعيه من الداخل ان ننتقل الى
هذا الى هذا التوقيت في هذا التوقيت الى
هذه المرحله اعتقد مشيت الله تعالى خلال
الربع الثاني من العام الجاري 2022
23 سيتم ان شاء الله تشغيل اول
فروع اطعام مدينه الدمام ومن ثم سوف تكون
هنالك سلسله فروع سواء في المنطقه الشرقيه
وفي باقي مناطق المملكه ان شاء الله شكرا
استاذ فيصل طبعا نايف هذه الجمعيه لديها
ناجحه جدا فيما يتعلق بالمتاجر
الالكترونيه كما نشاهد هذا موقع الجمعيه
نجحوا سابقا في تقديم عدد من الباقات
من يرغب بالتبرع واختيار السلال بعد شهر
ونصف تقريبا ستبدا هذه الجمعيه بتطبيق
المتجر السحابي عبر تطبيق
خاص عبر الاجهزه
الذكيه
البدء بهذه الخطوه التي ستشكل نقله كبيره
في
جمعيات الطعام في السعوديه سادع زميلي نصر
ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات كما نشاهد نحن في
وحده التعبئه مركزيه نايف هذه الصناديق
تذهب الى المستفيدين اولا باول من خلال
ادويه او السوري الاغذيه
الخاصه
بهم طبعا هذا المتجر نايف ما هي الفائده
منه انت عندما تريد ان تتبرع
للمحتاجين والمستفي تدخل الى السوبر ماركت
وتقول انا اليوم اريد التبرع مثلا بحليب
اطفال فقط او اريد التبرع مثلا بخضار او
فواكه فقط فتختار
البضائع او الاغذيه التي تريدها بالتحديد
ومن ثم تذهب الى المستفيدين ايضا سيتم
اختيار بعض المناطق الاكثر احتياجا ويتم
افتتاح السوبر ماركت فيها يستطيع المستفيد
بعبر بطاقه تموينيه ان ياتي الى هذا سو
ماركت وياخذ ما يريد من الاغذيه والاطعمه
طبعا اون لاين يستطيع ان يحصل على هذه
الاغذيه فعمل كبير ومؤسساتي وجهد صراحه
منقطع النظير من قبل هذه الجمعيه لتقديم
تجربه فريده وناجحه صحيح وواضح طبعا يا
عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك من مقر جمعيه
اطعام بالدمام الينا ممارسه العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي شكرا عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
في سوق العملات المشفره استمرت سلسله
الارتفاعات على اغلب العملات خاصه عمله
البيتكوين مع ارتفاع شهيه المستثمرين
للمخاطره على الرغم من تحركات ماليه
الرقابيه امريكيه استهدفت اساس هذه السوق
وهي العملات المستقره المزيد في هذا
التقرير
بعد الارتفاعات الكبيره لسوق العملات
المشفره في يناير والتي تجاوزت الاربعين
في المئه لعمله البيتكوين المحرك الرئيس
لهذه السوق يبدو ان زخم هذه الارتفاعات لم
يهدا بعد على الرغم من توجهات رقبيه وعلى
راسها الامريكيه بتضييق الخناق على هذا
السوق ففي الايام الاخيره امر كل من هيئه
الاوراق الماليه والبورصات واداره الخدمات
الماليه في ولايه نيويورك ان واي دي اف اس
شركه باكسوس المرخصه بوقف اصدار عمله بي
يو اس دي المستقره والتي تتبع اكبر منصه
تداول في العالم
هجوم السلطات الرقابيه الماليه جاء بحجه
تصنيف هذه العمله على انها ورقه ماليه غير
مرخصه وهذا ما قد يفتح الباب واسعا امام
تصنيف جميع العملات المستقره كاوراق ماليه
وفي هذه الحاله فان اس اي سي المسؤوله عن
تنظيمها بل وايقافها في حال مخالفتها
قواعد الهيئه ما ان جاء القرار بايقاف
باكسوس وعمله بي يو اس تي حتى دفعت الثمن
سريعا بتراجع عملتها بي ان بي تراجعا
حاديا تجاوز 15% لكن المؤسسه سيزي غرد
سريعا لانقاذ الموقف وتوضيحه بان باينانس
قد تبحث عن عمله مستقره اخرى بعيدا عن
الولايات المتحده لضمان العمليات والعملاء
وهو منعكس على وقف نزيف بي ام بي على
الاقل في الوقت الحالي استهداف السلطات
الرقابيه الماليه للسوق الكريبتو هذه
المره جاء بنتائج عكسيه فحظر عمله بي يو
اس تي دفع المستثمرين الى تحويل حيازتهم
فيها الى عمله مشفره اخرى امن منها
وبالطبع كانت عمله البيتكوين افضل
الخيارات بجانب عمله يو اس دي تي المستقره
وهو ما دعم الارتفاعات
على البيتكوين
تحرك سوق العملات المشفره يعتمد على شهيه
المخاطره للمستثمرين وهو ما دعمه ارتفاع
الاسواق الماليه وتراجع التضخم وتخفيف
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي للهجته في رفح اسعار
الفائده لكن السلطات الرقابيه ما زالت ترى
بان تنظيم السوق على راس اولوياتها وذلك
لمحاربه السرقات وغسيل الاموال شادي
الزعيم العربيه
قسم العرب والمطر الى ثمانيه اقسام منها
الرداد والديم والوابل التفاصيل مع خالد
الزعل
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد امه من الامم اهتمت بتفاصيل
ودقائق السماء من نجم وسدم ورعد وبرق كحال
الامه العربيه ليش لانهم اهل تنقل وترحل
في صحراء متراميه الاطراف ومتشابهه
المعالم فهم يعتمدون على النجوم في تنقلهم
وترحلهم وفصولهم ومواسمهم فعلاقتهم بسماء
علاقه حياتيه وجوديه تطورت الى علاقه
وجدانيه اقلب طرفي في السماء لعله يوافق
طرف طرفها
حين تنظر
[تصفيق]
والعرب قسموا المطره الى الرذاذ قطرات
المطره خفيفه والعامه يسمونه بالذرذر الرش
هو المطر الخفيف الدين هو المطر الدائم
الهتان هو المطر المتتابع الوابل هو
المطره غزير ذات الحبه الكبيره الحياه هو
الذي يحيي الارض الغيث هو الذي ياتينا بعد
انقطاع طويل الغدق المطر الغزير وان لو
استقاموا على الطريقه لاسقيناهم ماء غدقه
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم ودعوات اوروبيه للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات على مقياس
ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
مشروع لتحويل فائض الاطعمه والمشروبات الى
سوق غير ربحيه شرقي السعوديه
شكرا لكرمي اللطف المتابعه نهايه الرابعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]